deuxième tour Arthur rinderkness dernier
tricolore en lice et bien battu hier
soir mais il a dû s'incliner en cas de
cette façon numéro 8 mondiale
l'Américain Taylor frites
[Musique]
merci Xavier d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
des Hauts-de-Seine donc du groupe RPI ce
sont les sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on va commencer par
l'actualité politique de la semaine
c'est cette PPL du groupe lyaute qui a
donc été examinée à l'Assemblée
nationale mais en commission il a été
voté la suppression de l'article
principal qui visait à revenir sur la
retraite à 64 ans est-ce que cette
victoire de courte durée est-ce que ça
pourrait être une victoire de courte
durée pour la majorité présidentielle
qui pourrait conduire à une crise
institutionnelle je pense que c'est déjà
bien de rappeler que le texte a été voté
et que la suppression a été votée par
les députés de la majorité mais aussi de
certains de l'opposition et donc quand
certains
appellent un déni de démocratie le fait
que il n'y ait pas eu de vote qu'on
empêche les députés de voter en est que
en commission les députés ont pu voter
ont pu s'exprimer et
est plutôt là et les filles même
particulièrement est un peu un
comportement d'enfant gâté c'est à dire
que lorsqu'ils n'ont pas ce qu'ils
veulent ils font ils font du bruit de
l'obstruction il dépose mille
amendements parce que le résultat du
vote ne leur convient pas et donc on est
bien loin des révolutionnaires de 1789
qui n'ont pas été examinés du coup c'est
sous amendement ça a été la décision de
l'enterrement de la présidente de la
commission la nude dit que la majorité
mais la démocratie en danger qu'est-ce
que vous dites de ça mais ce qui est
mais en danger la démocratie c'est
l'obstruction organisée systématique qui
empêche en fait d'avoir le débat et qui
empêche de faire ce que les députés et
les sénateurs ont comme mission
c'est-à-dire de voter la loi à partir du
moment où on est élu parlementaire on
doit être là pour faire la loi pour
écrire la loi et pour la voter une ciné
la multiplication des obstructions
organisées par RFI ne fait que bloquer
la démocratie et ça c'est un vrai déni
de démocratie effectivement mais alors
du coup parce que il y aura l'examen en
séance le 8 juin prochain de Courson qui
est le rapporteur du texte a déjà dit
qu'il redéposerait l'amendement pour
revenir sur la retraite à 64 ans est-ce
qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout et ne pas
brandir l'article 40 mais moi je vous
savez il y a un principe qui peut
particulièrement énerver les
parlementaires et j'en suis j'en ai fait
des frais longtemps c'est cet article 40
effectivement qui fait que un
parlementaire ne peut pas aggraver la
dette de l'État ne peut pas créer une
charge supplémentaire sans avoir de
financement sans le gager en face c'est
insupportable quand on est parlementaire
parce qu'on a l'impression d'être bloqué
mais c'est aussi protecteur pour nos
finances publiques et donc il finit pour
les contribuables français donc cet
article 40 Charles de Courson est une
découvre pas ce n'est pas un article qui
débarque depuis Emmanuel Macron il a
toujours été là dans notre Constitution
et Charles de conscient ça fait 30 ans
qu'il est élu député donc il connaît
parfaitement et il était d'ailleurs
garant des finances publiques pendant 30
ans donc il connaît parfaitement cet
article de notre Constitution donc oui
effectivement quand il a fait il a fait
cette proposition de réintégration il le
finance il le gage pourquoi par
l'augmentation du prix du tabac ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui si on il faut être
transparent aussi avec les français si
on suivait la logique de Charles de
Courson et du groupe liotte et ça veut
dire que le paquet de cigarettes
montrait à 700 euros le paquet je pense
que c'est peu réalisable mais 700 euros
700 € le truc de du paquet de cigarettes
donc je pense qu'il faut être aussi un
peu cohérent avec avec la réalité et
avec l'incompréhension le côté
incompréhensible de cette proposition
mais l'opposition vous dit mais vous
aussi la majorité vous déposez des
propositions de loi qui sont engagées
sur la taxe tabac qui sont aussi
coûteuses pour les finances publiques
ils ont pris l'exemple notamment de la
PPL sur le Bien Vieillir pourquoi ce qui
pourrait marcher pour vous ne marcherait
pas parce que encore une fois je l'ai
seuls qui sont en capacité de lever le
gage donc le financement c'est le
gouvernement il y a que dans la
Constitution seul le gouvernement peut
aggraver la dette créer une dépense
supplémentaire il est pas
inédit que le gouvernement lève le gage
sur un certain nombre d'amendements ou
de propositions y compris venant de
l'opposition parce que ça va dans le bon
sens et ça va ça va être dans une
amélioration du service aux Français là
on peut pas dire que ce soit le cas on
va parler de l'actualité de cette
semaine au Sénat la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale poursuivi ces auditions sur
le fond Marianne on fait le point avec
Quentin calmé
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Xavier acoly bonjour et Quentin cette
semaine au Sénat les représentants de
deux associations bénéficiaires du fond
Marianne et sous le feu des critiques
étaient auditionné et leur représentant
était bien à la peine au moment de
justifier de leur utilisation de ce fond
voilà ces deux associations étaient les
principales bénéficiaires du fond
Marianne avec chacune plus de 300000
euros de subventions on rappelle le fond
Marianne lancé en avril 2021 par Marlène
Schiappa visite à créer des contenus
pour défendre la laïcité sur Internet
après l'assassinat terrible de Samuel
patibt la première association s'appelle
l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et préparation militaire on
voit son président son représentant qui
était reçu au Sénat hier en fait c'est
une vieille association qui a été créée
à la fin du 19e siècle qui semblait
presque même inactive jusqu'à ce qu'elle
touche des subventions de ce fond
Marianne elle avait par exemple en 2020
seulement 50000 euros de budget 5
adhérents mais fait étonn c'est le
cabinet de Marlène Schiappa qui aurait
proposé à cette association de
candidater pour bénéficier du fond
Marianne alors à quoi lui ont servi les
350 000 euros de subvention il y a bien
des vidéos qui ont été tournées quelques
tweets quelques dizaines ou de centaines
de tweets qui ont été réalisés mais de
la même du comité interministériel qui
distribuait le fond Marianne le bilan de
l'association était maigre regardez
effectivement ce qui écrit le comité
interministériel sur et bien le bilan de
l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et préparations services
militaire ce son projet
hilaïque highlighi il a acquis 1700
abonnés au total sur les trois
plateformes Twitter Tik Tok et Instagram
avec 500 publications au total et de la
même du comité qui distribue le fond
Marianne malgré une stratégie
publication régulière l'engagement en
ligne a été très faible ce qu'on en a
compris en fait avec ces auditions
mercredi c'est que la subvention du
fromage a surtout servi financer les
salaires des dirigeants de l'association
écoutez cet échange entre le rapporteur
de la commission d'enquête du Sénat et
le président des associations bon vous
expliquer que les charges de personnel
qui pourtant sont réduites par rapport à
l'ambition initiale de 6 à 2 et demi
équivalent en plein que les charges de
personnel pèsent aussi lourd près de 80%
dans votre budget on était
c'est tout ce dont je vous ai parlé au
départ la dénaturation du projet au
départ c'est qu'on était arrivé à un
seuil critique donc je vous suis sur la
réduction du nombre de personnels etc
quand effectivement on n'a pas tous les
budgets mais là nous étions plus que
l'équipe minimum voilà ces échanges sont
révélateurs des dérives de cette
association selon les sénateurs que nous
avons interrogé écoutez à notre micro
Daniel broyer sénateur membre de la
commission d'enquête il parle de
république des copains avec ce qui s'est
joué autour de cette association
l'essentiel de cette subvention 77%
salaire mais pour l'essentiel entre
salaire entre monsieur Sifaoui et le
président donc deux personnes prennent
la subvention et la production est assez
faible et comme ces deux personnes ont
été choisies dans une connivence disons
plutôt que sur sans doute sur un
discours sur sur une parole qui
séduisait le cabinet de la ministre
peut-être la ministre elle-même mais
sans sans qu'on puisse avoir la preuve
de leurs compétences sur les réseaux
sociaux je précise que Mohamed VI le
responsable éditorial de cette
association devait être également reçu
mercredi il n'était pas présent pour des
raisons médicales mais les sénateurs
vont demander à l'entendre dans les
prochaines semaines première question
Xavier Daniel Boyer qui parle de
république des copains notamment un
spécifiquement sur ces 350 000 euros de
subventions pour cette association
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez moi je
réponds déjà que je salue l'initiative
des parlementaires moi je ne remets
jamais en question les pouvoirs du
Parlement je pense que c'est salutaire
que
une deuxième association Quentin était
auditionnée mercredi oui elle visait que
produire des contenus qui était beaucoup
plus politiques effectivement c'est une
association qui a été montée je crois
trois mois avant le début de son
activité avec avec ce fond mariage des
associations qui publient des contenus
politiques mais financés par un fond qui
a été contre la laïcité est-ce que ça ça
vous pose problème mais moi ça me pose
problème et ça me pose problème dans
l'ensemble c'est à dire qu'on voit
effectivement ça tombe de dérive de même
certaines communes je pense d'ailleurs à
la ville de Paris qui est qui finance
également une association qui prône la
désobéissance civile que je pense que
c'est ce sujet-là effectivement les
fonds publics ne doivent pas être
utilisés à des fins partisanes ou en
tout cas pour prôner la désobéissance
civique donc oui je suis d'accord avec
vous il faut faire la lumière et il faut
condamner ce qui ne va pas dans
l'intérêt général de l'utilisation des
fonds publics
et bien le préfet Christian gravelle qui
dirige le comité qui a distribué le fond
Marianne au fur et à mesure des
auditions on a l'impression qu'en fait
le cabinet de Marlène Chapa avait quand
même beaucoup de responsabilités dans le
choix des bénéficiaires de ces
subventions est-ce que c'est
problématique que ce soit pas
l'administration qui décide de qu'est-ce
qui bénéficie des fonds mais un cabinet
qui est dirigé par des personnalités
politiques c'est peut-être encore une
fois moi je n'ai pas le je ne suis pas
membre de la commission donc je peux pas
juger de des différentes bénédictions ce
que je viens d'expliquer bah l'idée bien
sûr moi je préfère que ça soit
l'administration et que ça soit
généralement un préfet qui qui prennent
en charge après c'est pas le il y a pas
de sujet Marlène Schiappa il y a pas de
sujets du cabinet il est question de me
faire la lumière sur l'utilisation de
ses fonds est-ce que c'est fonds ont été
utiles pour lutter contre la
radicalisation et pour promouvoir la
laïcité oui ou non c'est ça en fait
on verra pour l'instant il y a une il y
a une instruction judiciaire la ministre
je voulais pas mise en cause directement
elle
s'est expliquée il faudra elle sera
auditionnée je crois par la commission
la semaine prochaine
la ministre c'est la Cour de justice de
République qui peut le faire tout à fait
la lumière même si même pas en cause la
ministre elle va faire la lumière sur
l'utilisation de ses fonds
de la semaine à tout à l'heure Quentin
on va parler de votre actualité au Sénat
Xavier puisque vous avez déposé une
proposition de loi pour supprimer le
délai de prescription en cas de violence
sexuelle sur un mineur avant de parler
du du fond de votre texte et de ce que
contient le texte est-ce que c'est
d'abord un message aux victimes que vous
voulez adresser une manière de libérer
leurs paroles c'est avant tout un
message aux victimes c'est faire en
sorte que les victimes
comprennent que quel que soit l'âge où
il décide de parler où ils arrivent
enfin à libérer la parole l'état
l'institution la République sera
toujours là à leur écoute pour les
accompagner et pour faire en sorte que
si tenter que ça soit possible il puisse
elle puisse se reconstruire et donc on
voit bien que les remontées de terrain
que nous avons montrent que on arrive à
libérer la parole parfois quand on est
grand-parents soi-même et donc
généralement à plus de 60 ans donc on
voit bien que le délai de prescription
actuelle qui est déjà assez longue mais
30 ans à partir de 18 ans il a une
montant pour un viol et 10 à 20 ans il a
nettement évolué sous le quinquennat du
président Macron et pour vous c'est pas
suffisant c'est pas suffisant parce
qu'en fait il y a cette histoire de coup
près de l'âge qui peut bloquer et qui et
qui est une deuxième violence en fait
pour la pour les victimes il y a la
première violence qui est forcément
l'acte en
soi et la deuxième voyance c'est quand
l'institution dit madame monsieur
vous n'êtes pas une victime parce que
vous n'avez pas parlé assez tôt et donc
c'est il n'y a rien de pire en fait pour
pour une victime quand elle a le courage
quand elle arrive enfin à libérer la
parole et que les traumatismes lui
permettent malgré tout la sortie du
traumatisme lui permet de prendre de
prendre la parole il n'y a rien de pire
que l'institution puisse rejeter cette
cette demande donc oui effectivement la
suppression du délai de prescription
pour les viols et violences sur mineur
me paraît indispensable et il y a aussi
un autre élément qui est important c'est
la non dénonciation la non révélation de
ses actes qui a nettement évolué sous le
précédent quinquennat en 2021 notamment
où on est passé entre 10 et 20 ans pour
le délai de prescription je rappelle
qu'il était à 4 ans et donc on a par
contre un besoin de clarifier ces délits
de non dénonciation
je veux déjà faire que tout soit aligné
sur 20 ans de prescription sur la non
dénonciation la non-réviation d'un acte
de violence vous rappelez
en 2021 ça évolue en 2021 entre 10 et 20
ans moi je veux tout mettre à 20 ans et
notamment c'était suite à l'affaire
Barbarin qui pour non dénonciation des
actes commis dans dans l'église je
rappelle c'est environ 330 000 les
estimations c'est 330 000 jeunes mineurs
qui ont été agressés sexuellement dans
l'Église c'est à peu près 13 jeunes par
jour depuis les années 70 c'est énorme
et donc et ça ce n'est que dans la
partie église donc on voit bien qu'il y
a un vrai sujet qui a été dénoncé
régulièrement et donc il y a aussi une
responsabilité de ceux qui ne dénoncent
pas et qui ne révèle pas ses actes de
violence sexuelle sur mineur sur
l'imprescriptibilité alors c'est
contesté par certains avocats par la
Chancellerie est-ce que vous êtes sûr
que ça va passer et est-ce que c'est
vous êtes sûr que c'est constitutionnel
d'élargir la prescription le Conseil
d'État
le Conseil d'État et le Conseil
constitutionnel avait déjà émis un avis
sur la capacité du gouvernement à
supprimer un certain nombre de délais de
prescription donc ça on a déjà le fait
constitutionnel sur le fait que c'est
possible ensuite il y a un choix
politique et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut aussi écouter les Français on nous
demande toujours d'écouter les Français
les Français aujourd'hui ne supportent
plus l'impunité qu'on peut avoir que
certains auteurs peuvent avoir sur
justement ces violences sur mineur il
n'est pas question d'aller jusqu'à la
peine de mort j'entendais certains
détracteurs qui disaient si on écoute ça
on peut aller jusqu'à la peine de bord
la question est de dire il n'y a pas
d'impunité sur les violences et les les
viols sur sur mineur et donc oui il faut
évoluer la Chancellerie doit évoluer et
notre droit doit évoluer il a toujours
évolué et la question de la
prescriptibilité n'est pas
inconstitutionnel et surtout il faut
regarder autour de nous on est toujours
en train de nous comparer avec d'autres
pays la Suisse les Pays-Bas la Belgique
ce sont des pays qui ont fait évoluer
leur législation dernièrement c'est à
dire depuis 2020
il y a tous ces pays qui ont évolué et
je ne parle même pas du Royaume-Uni qui
traditionnellement n'a pas de délai de
prescription pour les violences sur
mineures mais les Français aidencent
aussi les lenteurs de la justice
peut-être parfois un manque d'écoute
peut-être parfois aussi un certain
laxisme est-ce que c'est pas aussi
là-dessus qu'il faut travailler mais
c'est un autre volet la rapidité et
l'exécution des peines ça c'est un
travail que le garde des sceaux hérite
Dupond-Moretti mène depuis qu'il est
garde des sceaux et pour le coup on met
les moyens nécessaires l'augmentation
des budgets pour pour ralentir mais
justement accélérer les les procédures
mais c'est autre chose là moi ce que je
veux c'est que la justice ne soit pas
seulement tournée sur les auteurs mais
soit se tourner aussi vers les victimes
et que la justice soit
justement c'est d'ailleurs pour ça c'est
pour ça que moi je veux que la justice
puisse dire aux victimes nous serons là
quelle que soit le moment où vous
prendrez la parole et vous déciderez de
libérer la parole et c'est ça je moi je
souhaite une justice qui soit
réparatrice et qui accompagne des
victimes et si ça passe seulement
uniquement tourné sur les auteurs vous
êtes optimiste sur être examinée à
l'automne à la rentrée en théorie quelle
est assez transpartisane vous êtes
optimiste sur les transports
d'horizon du groupe des indépendants par
certains de l'Union centriste des
républicains également et je sais que
même si traditionnellement il ne signe
pas de proposition de loi d'autres
groupes je sais que sur les rangs de la
gauche il y a aussi des forces soutien
sur sur cette proposition donc oui j'ai
bon espoir qu'elle puisse passer si
tenter qu'on puisse l'inscrire à
l'agenda du Sénat
dans nos régions on va aller du côté
d'Aurillac retrouver pierre Reynaud
bonjour Pierre merci d'être avec nos
directeurs départementales de l'édition
du Cantal au journal La Montagne pierre
on va parler d'un tout autre sujet avec
vous on va parler du train de nuit entre
Paris et Aurillac c'est pour bientôt
mais pas forcément comme vous le
souhaitez
oui bonjour à tous
[Musique]
Aurillac est considéré comme la
préfecture la plus enclavée de France
donc elle bénéficie à ce titre d'une
liaison aérienne qui est largement
subventionnée par l'État par des
rotations quotidiennes à Paris pour un
aménagement du territoire plus
harmonieux Jean castexte quand il
s'était passé en 2021 et annoncé le
retour du train de nuit à Aurillac
pour 2023 2024 le retour il est acté on
l'a pris en fin de semaine dernière il a
été pour le 10 décembre prochain mais ce
train de circulera uniquement le
week-end et pendant les vacances
scolaires parisiennes donc c'est
orientation a été très mal accueillie
dans le Cantal où on a l'impression
d'être traités comme un territoire de
seconde zone les élus qui avaient salué
en 2021 l'annonce de Jean Castex refuse
ce train de nuit au rabais avec une
vision très parisienne ils ne veulent
pas d'un train touristique ont-ils
martelé la semaine dernière mais d'une
ligne d'équilibre du territoire alors
que l'État annonce aujourd'hui sa
volonté de renforcer les transports
décarbonés et le ferroviaire en
particulier comment jugez-vous monsieur
le sénateur ses incohérences du
gouvernement
oui je connais pas particulièrement le
dossier
particulièrement du Cantal mais mais je
pense que il faut quand même saluer que
c'est sous ce quinquennat et sous la
présidence de d'Emmanuel Macron que nous
avons réinvesti dans le ferroviaire nous
avons réinvesti dans les petites lignes
celle qui avait été pendant des années
laissées à l'abandon et donc je rappelle
que c'est un plan de 100 milliards
d'euros d'investissement sur le
ferroviaire et sur les petites lignes
d'ici à 2040 et donc c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle que ce genre de ligne
puisse être remise en circulation moi je
fais confiance aussi à mes collègues
parlementaires et à la concertation qui
va continuer pour faire en sorte que les
horaires puissent évoluer et je pense
qu'il faut aller dans ce sens là après
moi je ne connais pas ni la rentabilité
ni l'utilisation réelle de ces lignes et
les besoins réels de de ce territoire
pardonnez-moi mais c'est vrai que moi je
suis dans les Hauts-de-Seine et donc du
coup plus se concentrer sur la question
des transports franciliens mais il y a
un vrai sujet il y a en fait c'est le
sens de l'histoire le sens de l'histoire
c'est plus de transport collectif plus
de transport propre et c'est exactement
ce que le gouvernement fait avec ce plan
de 100 milliards d'investissement dans
dans le ferroviaire
merci Pierre Renaud merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous depuis Aurillac on
regarde la une de la montagne dans son
édition du Cantal ça parle sport final
U17 et U19 fleur de vérités c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
pierre Renaud d'avoir été avec nous on
va parler des sénatorial pour terminer
puisque la haute font partie des
départements renouvelables vous êtes
candidats d'abord Xavier à votre
succession et vous est-ce que vous êtes
sûr d'être investibles présidentielle
parce qu'on sait qu'il y a des
discussions entre Renaissance le modem
et horizon pour savoir quelles sont les
playlists qu'elles vont être les
candidats votre place est assuré je suis
aujourd'hui investi par Renaissance par
le Président de la République pour mener
la liste de la majorité présidentielle
dans les Hauts-de-Seine c'est confirmé
j'ai commencé ma campagne et je suis aux
côtés des élus comme je suis depuis
maintenant un peu plus de 5 ans et demi
et oui j'ai bon espoir de revenir au
mois de septembre au Sénat il y a pas de
problème entre les différentes
composantes de la majorité on entend
notamment le nom d'Isabelle Floren qui
est modem qui était député qui a été
battu au législatives et qui
convoiterait une place au Sénat est-ce
qu'il y a des discussions avec elle il y
a des discussions forcément il y a des
discussions avec les partis politiques
qui composent la majorité c'est toujours
comme ça dans les investitures moi j'ai
bon espoir que au niveau national nous
trouvions des accords pour faire en
sorte que la majorité présidentielle
puisse gagner un maximum de sièges que
ça soit pour horizon pour le modèle ou
pour Renaissance c'est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui de de ces élections pour
pour le mois de septembre après il y a
des particularités départementales il y
a effectivement des candidats qui ont
été battus aux élections législatives
qui souhaitent récupérer un autre mandat
national je n'ai pas connaissance de
plus de candidatures que ça mais en tout
cas moi la volonté que j'ai que je mène
c'est de faire en sorte que nous ayons
une liste majorité présidentielle unie
pour les départements des Hauts-de-Seine
et ce sera le cas elle sera porté par
vous et il y aura bien une liste
majorité et vous êtes optimiste sur le
fait que vous pourrez garder le siège de
la majorité présidentielle
je suis optimiste
plus généralement au niveau national on
disait effectivement il y a des
discussions entre les trois composantes
de la majorité est-ce que vous pensez
que des accords seront trouvés partout
ou est-ce qu'il y aura forcément des
divergences il y a une volonté des trois
partis politiques de trouver un accord
large puisque ça va dans l'intérêt en
fait de chacun des composants de la
majorité présidentielle ça va intérer
notre majorité dans son ensemble et donc
oui il y a des discussions qui qui
durent mais comme au niveau des
législatives ça avait duré il y avait
forcément des non pas des tensions mais
des velléités de part et d'autre et donc
c'est le principe des négociations entre
partenaires je pense que nous arriverons
à trouver d'ici mi-juin ou aller on va
dire fin juin pour être pessimiste un
accord global sur l'ensemble des
territoires renouvelables du fait que
Renaissance a automatiquement réinvesti
ces sortants laissant de facto peu de
place à la discussion dans les dans les
endroits où les sortants étaient là
alors peu de place je dirais pas ça il y
a 12 sortants il y a 170 sénateurs à
renouveler je pense que pour le coup les
discussions étaient très larges sur la
possibilité de soutenir d'autres
candidats sur d'autres territoires et le
principe un peu général qu'on a aussi
mené lors des élections législatives
c'est que on soutenait les sortants
qu'on ce qui soit députés ou qui soit
sénateurs donc il est normal qu'on puis
nous puissions soutenir les sénateurs
sortant horizons les sénateurs sortant
en modem et donc les sénateurs sortant
en Renaissance c'est un principe de base
après il y a des discussions
effectivement département par
département le MoDem qui siège à l'heure
actuelle dans le groupe udaïs
c'est-à-dire dans la majorité
sénatoriale il y a un groupe les
indépendants qui regroupent la plupart
des sénateurs horizons puis il y a le
groupe RDPI qui regroupe les sénateurs
Renaissance est-ce que pour vous il faut
un groupe unique la majorité
présidentielle à partir du mois
d'octobre je ne sais pas si c'est utile
ce qui est utile c'est de faire en sorte
que nous soyons cohérents avec notre
appartenance à la majorité
présidentielle et nos choix et nos votes
au sein du Parlement c'est pas forcément
un seul groupe je pense que ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir une diversité on
vient pas de toutes de la même famille
politique on a des sensibilités
différentes et la particularité du Sénat
fait que nous pouvons avoir des petits
groupes de sensibilité qui nous
permettent de porter des projets mais
avec une seule ambition celle de
soutenir le projet présidentiel merci
Xavier merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure
dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on reviendra sur la bataille
politique autour de la proposition de
loi du groupe liote qui vise à abroger
la retraite à 64 ans mais d'abord on va
parler de la guerre en Ukraine avec les
deux invités qui nous rejoindre tout de
suite